Attentive!
And what position will act
Spain in the Eurovision semifinal,
2 024?
Then stay until the end of the video
because I'm going to tell you everything and you're going to freak out.
Follow me so you don't miss the Eurovision news,
music and salseos?
Did you hear that right?
Semifinal and Spain?
This year's Big Five
will perform in the semifinals,
but in the semifinals it will not be possible to vote for them
because they go directly to the final.
For those who don't know,
countries that pass directly through
to the final every year are Spain,
France,
Italy,
United Kingdom and Germany.
Sweden will also advance directly to the final,
for winning the festival in 2023.
So these 6 countries will play in the semifinals.
even if they pass directly
to the final. And well,
as we already know
in which position Spain will play in the semifinals.
Yes,
fantasy.
Spain will play in the second semifinal.
As you can see,
the second semifinal is opened by Malta and closed by Malta.
Netherlands,
and Spain will operate between Latvia and San Marino,
that this is quite funny,
because San Marino will perform after Spain,
represented by Megara,
who are also from Spain.
Italy will also play in the second semifinal
between Estonia and Israel,
as will France,
which will operate between the Czech Republic and Austria.
The first semifinal will be opened by Cyprus and closed by Cyprus.
Luxembourg.
As you can see,
The United Kingdom will act between Ireland and Ukraine,
Germany will operate between Iceland and Slovenia,
and Sweden,
between Moldova and Romania.
What do you think
Spain's place in the Eurovision semifinal?
2,024?
Leave it for me on